[Music]
going so we wake up buddy
mommy let's wake up let's go baby
swingin homie man and wake up get up
wake your ass up Zoe
[Music]
hey where's mom she left us and this
time it's for good no thanks to you guys
then right you leave this list because I
mess with you what does it say well it's
long laundry pick up clothes from
cleaner roving dogs scrub toilets
grocery shopping set up tax appointment
hey guys let's go guys come on let's go
hustle hustle up I saw you and they all
lived happily ever after the end
what a great story guys right so it's
time to go to sleep I'm tired I know you
guys are
yeah vestroia for you daddy about what a
famous comedian really let me guess his
name was table Rex no he acts okay what
happened he had a big special coming up
a super special special nice everybody
in the crowd was so excited to see t-rex
and then one of his comedian friends
brought him up on stage
all right ladies and gentlemen coming to
the stage please welcome one of the
funniest comedians and human beings that
I know the one and only mr. Todd wow
this is amazing this must be very
amazing for you you're welcome you're
welcome this must be very amazing for
you thank you guys for coming out this
is [ __ ] fantastic I can't tell you
how excited I am to be here right off
the bat I have four kids so I'm happy to
be anywhere
these [ __ ] aren't you know you
have kids you know what I'm talking
about you love and but sometimes you
just want to get the [ __ ] away from
people beating it is illegal so I just
go on the road for a few days my kids
cry Danny are you really leaving for
another five days I'm like a dude it's
five days or five to seven years mother
[ __ ] is about to catch a charge I could
be back Monday I can be back for
graduation
four of a man my oldest is 24 she
graduated from Wesleyan two years ago
and uh and our youngest isn't diapers
yeah he's 15 it's kind of [ __ ] up at
our house right now stop [ __ ] his
pants I can't tell if he's smart or
stupid [ __ ] dude just feeeeel [ __ ]
your pants was like dude you're still
changing them you got a point one of us
needs to knock this off
my kids will rob you of your time your
freedom your money your fun you know
your ability to stay up lay there take
all that but you'll go back and [ __ ]
make more let's do another one I don't
care my life is already over at this
point it's a gamble right and it's the
worst gamble the odds are horrible ten
minutes of ecstasy for 18 years of
responsibility there's a horrible odds
that's why I like old ladies now man
like hot ladies don't even turn me on
like hot girls hot chicks don't do it
for me anymore man because three of my
four kids were conceived what my wife
was on birth control
one was the pill and other two times was
IUD I don't even know what an IUD is my
wife tried to describe what it is to me
but all I can picture is it's not
working number one number two I can only
imagine it's like a crown on the tip of
my penis going to the
wakey wakey eggs and Bakey and he wants
eggs fertilized let's do this let's make
lives and rule them at the same time
that's why I like all these hot girls we
go to Vegas and we go all over the
country to see hot girls not like
naughty what do you think about her I'm
like yeah that's a baby waiting to
happen right there you know she's
fertile I'm potent I can't have that I
need an old lady in my life my friends
like ain't nothing wrong with a cougar
like cougar I need a saber-toothed I
need them old like no chance of
pregnancy like even if she does get
pregnant there's no way that she's gonna
make it to term either right you want to
turn me on tell me a last doctor's
appointment he told you to get your
affairs in order
that's what I want how'd it go with the
doctors let's go back to your house and
have sex in that hospital bed in the
living room I need the white hair
upstairs and downstairs
I won't even click on the video unless
the thumbnail looks like she's sitting
on a colonial wig I'm not bony old
ladies right but you know for kids
though man Wow that'll make it real
value 8 like I can't tell you how many
times like if you have kids you know
they always want to look at your phone
they want to talk to you XM Disney all
the other you know the [ __ ] that little
kids do and I just got to get away from
at least three times a day I act like
I'm takin a dump just to go in the
bathroom and get some peace and quiet
I'm sitting on the edge of the tub just
looking around the room checking stuff
out looking at grout lines I never used
to pay attention to grout lines I could
probably do those tiles better
I'm not even a homeowner like that like
all people to fix something like that if
I could do that better Danny what are
you doing in there I'm snapping off a
state pickle man what do you think I'm
doing well then why are you sitting on
the tub are you [ __ ] looking under
the door dude come on man give me some
privacy look man I pay the mortgage I'll
[ __ ] where I want alright would you pay
the mortgage you can take a dump in the
sink I don't care like this dude is
looking now I got to be a method actor
and I got to pull my pants and underwear
to the floor and be in front of the
toilet I'm not even sitting on the
toilet one time I was standing in from
the toilet pants and underwear around my
ankles and I got a glimpse of myself in
the mirror I looked awful telephone in
my hand t-shirt on and dick out like
Winnie the Pooh [ __ ] am i doing right
now
[Music]
but I do like to get out of the house
man for kids man my 24 year old is the
got to be the laziest kid on the [ __ ]
planet like she wanting to get her own
tampons I'm going to the store I'm like
she's where you going I'm going to the
store okay I'll see you when you get
back and then 10 minutes later so call
me Oh
are you at the store yet yeah I'm at the
store can you pick me up some tampons
I'm like why the [ __ ] didn't you add why
don't you come with me you knew I was
coming you can't get your own goddamn
tampons
see I hate buying to always feel like
I'm robbing a bank when I go in to buy
tampons I have to case the joint first I
forget walking around
make sure I don't know anybody in this
[ __ ] before I put some tampons
on the counter I don't know if you know
this ladies but guys we make judgments
on your vagina based on the tampons your
man puts on the counter I'm standing in
line behind a duty throws a box on the
counter oh my god damn super absorbent
with odor control hum [ __ ] if you even
want to go home right now like you're
[ __ ] out dude just keep [ __ ]
heading south the [ __ ] are you doing
oh dude surely supersized looks like a
stick of dynamite with a tugboat rope
hanging off the end of it cruise ship
docking rope I call my daughter oh my
god I'm talking to her on the phone oh
my gosh so which ones do you want she's
like I need you to get me the sport
tampons this oh my goodness is this
sport you're the laziest [ __ ] in the
house what the [ __ ] you need sport
tampons won't you be a sport get off the
[ __ ] couch and get your own [ __ ]
tampons stead of sending me down here
just look for the girl running on the
box no I'm not looking for the girl run
I'm looking for the [ __ ] chicken
laying on the couch with the crumbs on
her [ __ ] says [ __ ] remote control
and looking at the TV I want to see the
TV glow on the box on your face
lazy millennial tampons is a box of
balled up napkins you just put them on
your underwear who's the sport the sport
ones are just a couple tube socks this
is this is for tampons two sides
actually I don't mind going to the store
to get tampons that you know and said
getting tampons is a small price to pay
for 20 minutes of freedom out of the
house I'll go to the store get them damn
tampons but I got a sneak out of the
house my kids know I'm go to the store
they want to come with me the little
ones are like ice cream chips my [ __ ] I
got a sneak out so I open the garage
door go to the garage that I can't hear
me open the front door by the time they
realize I'm out of the house I'm already
sideways down the driveway that's my
time now I'm doing me if you're a parent
you know I'm talking about like you're
like holy [ __ ] I'm by myself oh my god
listen to hip-hop with all the cuss
words [ __ ] smoking weed in the car
mature Kitab so the bars up out of the
sunroof head out the window like a
Spencer my neighbors think I'm crazy
my 20 minute vacation to the store
always turns into nothing less than an
hour for no other reason than I
ejaculated and fell asleep in the
parking lot I'm ashamed to tell you how
many times I waking up 45 minutes later
with my dick stuck to my stomach
shuffling through the female products
[Music]
come home my wife was like really it
took you an hour to go to the store I'm
like I was looking for the specific
tampons with the chicken a kayak on the
boxes finally it feels like you jerked
off again didn't you
what it's ridiculous why would you think
I jumped off an apartment cuz when you
left the house you were wearing two
socks where's your other side never take
that you know you'd better hope no one
gets murdered in that parking lot we're
gonna scour the parking lot find one of
your nutty socks and tie you to that
murder
that's a preposterous hypothesis
fast forward to 2:30 in the morning I'm
losing sleep Restless laying in bed my
family but I love my kids man it's
beautiful man they they drive me nuts
but I wouldn't have it any other [ __ ]
way I have three girls and a boy my boys
the youngest he's not really 15 he's 7
and he's out of diapers but having three
girls is a lot different than having
boys my mom was like you have to raise
him on an equal playing field I'm like
you can't raise him on equal playing
field mom she's like why not and I was
like cuz girls are different than boys
it's just true you can't raise him the
same like say there's two parents
sitting at home and they both get a call
from the school and once the little boy
was a little girl and they call from the
school say hey we found a little girl in
the closet sucking a little boy's day
what's parent you want to be
right they're different like when you
got girls and is different from boys
like my son I just have to worry about
his dick with girls I'm gonna worry
about all the dicks and I hated all the
dicks are come to my house looking for
my older daughters they're all talking
all gentlemanly when they meet me like
all mr. Rex you got a nice house here
mr. bakshy must be doing very wealthy
yourself
oh is that this is what a study vision
of beauty now I see where you thought it
gets it from I ain't I what I can't
start doing this when he's looking at
your wife I my brother told me is like
look man you want to scare these kids
what you got to do is get a pistol clean
the pistol when they come over I'm not
gonna Kim I'm not cleaning the pistol in
front of these kids half these kids
probably got a better weaponry that I
got I start cleaning the gun the kid
walking oh I got one of those too except
my firing pins filed down so that shit's
Auto I'll let these kids know I'm crazy
on a whole nother level they come into
my house I scare the [ __ ] out on they
come to the door I see him pull up in
the driveway I come to the door and gear
I got my robe on some sandals in a
sombrero ass naked underneath this all
that [ __ ] wasn't my dick the semi it's
not hard is this enough that it's not
touching the nuts
the [ __ ] is wrong with me Oh
and slowly masturbate and make eye
contact the creepy eye contact with no
facial expression is what sells it like
just no like you're doing it but don't
even like creepy [ __ ] like yo come on in
young man have a seat next to that jar
of Vaseline with all the hair in it the
threat of getting touched by a grown
man's penis it's stronger than the
threat of getting shot like put a gun in
my face with my dick in my face I have
to like suit ah hit me in a vital organ
with the [ __ ] pills like that dick
ain't circumcised I don't know if I can
take that one
serious you don't think it big and scary
get in a fight see what happens you take
your dick out the dynamic of the fight
changes immediately you begin to ask me
Suzu dickham back
hey don't touch blue that dick or stop
playing man stop trying to get your
friends ate some tackle this
[ __ ] your friends like I'm not
getting my new shirt all Diggy
I'm glad you're right there with me I'm
sorry me and my wife we named all our
daughters together
Taylor Zoe and Zion my youngest daughter
Zion she's nine she asked where we got
the names from for our daughters where
are all the kids in the family and
Taylor was like yeah this should be fine
so we sat him down I was like all right
guys gather round let me tell you how
you got your names what they mean I was
like Zion since you asked what your name
means and where it came from well Zoe
used to love lions and she wanted to
name you an easy name but but she
decided how about Zion like lion but
with a Z so he names you Sian and it's
cool because I mean safe haven a
protector of man and she was like yay
and then Zoey was like what does my name
mean I was like Zoey means life and
that's exactly what you've given us by
being here you've given us life she's
like oh that's some sweet and Taylor's
like looking at her phone she was like
what does my name mean and I was like a
fixer of clothes
[Applause]
that's the first time I ever heard her
cuz she was like [ __ ] really it
was easy to name all our girls together
because we just sat down and we came up
with names together and it was a process
but I don't know what it was about after
having three girls having a boy finally
putting the stem on the Apple I wanted
to name my son I wanted him to have the
coolest name on the planet like you know
our last name is Rex which means King in
Latin it's a great last name so I'm not
gonna have him like Elliot
Rex name is Elliot I'm sorry okay but
Elliot Larry [ __ ] this guy Elliot's of
the world unite so I decided that I was
gonna be the sole one to name my son cuz
I have a pretty cool idea of what I want
to name my son a nakulan you know a
couple ideas and my wife is like we
should we should have a conversation
about what will maybe outshine and uh no
she doesn't really sound like that but
that's the voice I go to when I start
losing arguments and every guy in here
does that with their wife yo you're
coming over to watch the game yo I was
going to but then my wife came home
talking about
women you do the same thing you made it
you make it sound like a married the
dumbest dude on the planet you make my
wife does it all time I never said I was
taking the dish out of the dishwashers
it's like yes you did you were like all
right there's a dishes over the portable
way to be so proud of me and then I'm
gonna lay on the couch and scratch my
penis for three hor kids are watching
this [ __ ] like would you guys knock it
off it's a school night I'm trying to
with your mom or kids
so my wife is very intellectual she's
the smartest person outside of marrying
me she's the smartest [ __ ] person
I've ever met my life
that's her clapping like [ __ ] that's the
Banshee T saying alright so when I had
to shut the names down that she had
chosen I had you know I just had to shut
him I can't just say I don't like that
name I had to come up with a ridiculous
reason the more ridiculous
the reason the better it is for me
because it shows I put in some effort so
soon she I saw the list ahead of time so
I had [ __ ] planned so she was like okay
well I have some names I was like let me
hear these [ __ ] names you got picked
out I haven't started talking different
around the house I was like you like I'm
super macho about I was like let me hear
these names that you have picked out
these [ __ ] names what about the name
Cody I'm like death sentence she was
like what I was like Cody's don't live
to be old you've never met an 80 year
old Cody over 80 year olds is walking
around Shady Acres retirement community
hero they called me to the Closter
Tristan
Cody's always die young doing dumb [ __ ]
like X Games stuff wingsuiting and
jumping dirt bikes lost the X Games
watched how many kids are named Cody
those [ __ ] don't live long
she wouldn't name my son after me my
name is Todd I can't I it's not even a
name it's a sound ID it's not short for
anything my name is not Tata thin is
this [ __ ] tied my brother's name is
Greg but his full name is Gregory when
he got in trouble my mom was like
Gregory there's no way to [ __ ] extend
my name exist steps a longer time
maybe put another syllable in there
tired - oh [ __ ] your report cards out
stares hide it sounds like some caveman
[ __ ] doesn't really talk to Todd part
part hard consonant vowel consonant Todd
it's a sound it's the same sound of dirt
makes after rolls out of a giraffes ass
and I'm a light-skinned black dude named
Todd I don't sound scary at all you
described into somebody that doesn't a
light-skinned black dude named Todd like
I used to go to school with a kid named
Mike Thomas this kid was a blue-black
you see me like that it's like Superman
Harry like when Superman's hair gets hit
with us the light his hair looks blue
that's how this kid Mike was I was
sitting in math class one time and the
sunlight came through the window and hit
the back of Mike's neck and I was like
this blue my buddy Donny he was next to
me he was [ __ ] me he's like yeah I
met his parents his dad's a negro his
mom's a mailbox
his nickname was black Mike it sounds
[ __ ] up but there's 30 kids named Mike
in high school you didn't have to run
down their whole pedigree to say which
Mike you talked about [ __ ] black Mike
the purple kid from algebra got it it
sounds [ __ ] up it's a good way to like
narrow it now we had Chinese Mike the
fucked-up part about that is he was
Filipino like no one even no one even
put in the legwork to find out what kind
of Asian this guy was it's slanted eyes
Chinese Mike
that's high school we were idiots black
might got respect immediately because
his name was [ __ ] black and his name
was black Mike that's some scary [ __ ]
you sit in class in tenth grade someone
says a man I don't know what you did but
black Mike is looking for you you might
get a little nervous holy [ __ ] really I
gotta fight some dude named black Mike I
want to fight black Mike no I gotta go
to college in two years I didn't strike
that same fear in your heart you're
sitting in class and someone's at a man
I don't know what you did but beige Todd
is looking for you beige time let that
khaki kid from Home Economics man tell
him I said [ __ ] you would step on his
sandals for me my wife told me on
pantyhose color she said that right in
the middle of my argument it diffused
the argument immediately I couldn't
argue after that I started laughing
Elvis tonight [ __ ] you pantyhose color
by the [ __ ] I was like [ __ ] you that's
funny but [ __ ] you too I use that to my
advantage we start arguing about money
like what do you want to do is start
robbing banks I can't it but pantyhose
on my face I look exactly the [ __ ]
same I'm a black dude living in Los
Angeles I'm not allowed to buy a ski
mask I don't know if you know that black
people can't buy ski masks in warm
weather climates white people go into
big fire throw a [ __ ] ski mask on the
counter there bring him right up I throw
it on the counter they want to do a
background check was a three day waiting
period buying a gun okay really Kunta
Kinte you're heading up to the mountains
this weekend
hitting the slopes Aria yeah nice try
put it back not on my watch not on my
watch so my name was out of the question
she wanted to name my son chase my
daughter Zoey has two friends named
chase both great kids
athletes scholars great kids my wife was
like what's wrong with Chase who's named
our son chase and I was like we can't
name our son chase she was like why not
and I was like because there's no black
chases all the chases we know are white
she was like so and I was like so you
know how they call my friend black Mike
what are they gonna call our son chase
the black kid that sounds like a
horrible game played in Charlottesville
relax Malik chase , the black kid
punctuation is very important I made
t-shirts that I thought were hilarious
you know cuz I'm half black and half
white so my t-shirt said half black
lives matter and I sold these shirts and
this dude in Charlotte North Carolina
bought one serving on a Friday night and
brought it back Saturday he was like
dude he had it balled up in a bag just
like Texas [ __ ] back I don't even want
my [ __ ] money back I just gotta let
you know that I almost got killed
wearing that [ __ ] shirt and I was
like why and it was like cuz you need to
hyphenate half black because it just
says half black lives matter now I'm
walking around a white dude with a shirt
that says hat black lives matter like
not all you [ __ ] have matters the only
half you matter let's not be ridiculous
we need some [ __ ] down around here but
the rest of you go back to Africa
chase my wife was like this black is
named chase I was like you've never met
a black kid named chase it she started
looking up at the ceiling trying to find
the answer and I was like you've never
met a black kid named chase just like
you've never met a baby named Larry I
want y'all to think about that first
thing it isn't that so weird she'll I
think about everybody in this room knows
hilarya but not a single person in this
room has ever met a baby named Larry
where the [ __ ] are they coming from if
they've never been babies right you
didn't know a Larry growing up you met
Larry in your 20s that's because that's
how old they are when they let him out
of the [ __ ] factory or the lab or
whatever it is so I can Larry a51
wherever that is
Larry's 25 26 years old they open the
lab let him out he's [ __ ] stumbled
into societies he's afraid he doesn't
know anybody that's why all your friends
named Larry is a great [ __ ] guy he's
a sweetheart he just wants to be
accepted it'll give you the last dollar
out of his pocket it'll help you move
without asking for anything in return
great [ __ ] guy sweetheart never been
a [ __ ] baby but a great [ __ ] guy
you think I'm bullshitting ask your
friend Larry to see a baby picture he
can't produce it it's creepy let me see
a baby picture Larry come on man you
know that got burned up in the fire of
96 you're never a [ __ ] baby Larry
I'm on to you Larry whatever your real
name is experiment six to six or whoever
you are so yeah man like I said my last
name is Rex which means king in Latin
that's why I go by t-rex a lot of the
time people ask me like why you go by
t-rex like comedians I check in the
hotel like your real last name is Rex
I'm like yeah [ __ ] that's where
T I'm Todd Rex
Taylor Rex Zoe Rex Zion Rex Sarah Rex
Marguerite back Rex Greg Rex it's my
whole family so what did I name my son
you might be asking probably the coolest
name on the [ __ ] planet my son's name
is Maximus Rex
Maximus Rex
when he came out of hell the bubbles
like leader of the free people General
of the Republic sorry my wife is still
on drugs on the bed like don't forget
son of Base tried
ruin my moment she was appalled by the
name she's like I really the namings
dude Maximus Rex really his name is
Maximus Rex he's either gonna be a
Dragon Slayer or a hairdresser and
Dragons aren't real so prepare for Salon
Maximus okay it's a lot Maximus she kept
on singing with that super wet
effeminate s you know I go I see I hear
it all the time I go into stores with my
kids and I can't say the name of the
store but let's just say it's like one
less than forever 22 I walk in with my
daughters and looking for some earrings
or whatever like no sir is there
something I can help you search for
something special for that certain
someone perhaps some like damn dude yeah
my daughter's looking for some earrings
oh you want to talk this even from
accessories Steven from accessories I'm
summoning you sir Stephen comes prancing
in and pops all the do to the bottom
stop Steven you stab it I'm still sore
from Sunday's escapades and I'm joking
obviously I don't want anybody to get
offended this guy came out I was doing a
show in Vegas a few a few months back
and this guy came up to me up on the
shores in the casino excuse me sir and I
was like what's up man it was like I
just saw your show and I was like oh
nice and he was like nice I wasn't
giving you kudos I was like oh I've
never heard that word used for real
before like like in the wild I've never
heard that
kudos where they do that at
and he was like actually I have a bone
to pick with you and I was like this is
gonna be [ __ ] worse I bombed the Big
O it was like actually I was defended at
your ridiculous choice of
characterizations or whatever it's
called an impersonation when you were
doing the super wet ass it was
ridiculous I'm like like the one you're
[ __ ] doing right now he's like what
guess [ __ ] and before you ask I am on
the other team and I was like I wasn't
gonna ask
and he was like what I'm saying is you
being a comedian so many years I thought
you'd be a little more creative and
maybe come up with a different voice
than the most stereotypical one out
there maybe try a different one and I
was like it's like not all gay men sound
like this and I was like all right man I
wasn't trying to make it sound like all
gay men sound like that alright I
apologize if I offended you
he was like thank you and I was like
although not all gay men sound like that
I will say that all men that sound like
that are gay
and he accepted that we can't do a happy
meeting he was like Touche Touche and it
[ __ ] me up then he complimented me on
my show and then he left but the [ __ ]
up thing was his face left about a
second and a half after his body it was
like you were fantastic otherwise his
body numers gone before his face but
that's confidence your body just starts
to leave me when you're like his body is
like I'm out of here his face is like
I'm gonna take a couple more seconds up
wrists out his wrists knew when they
were going to they're all going this way
I have a friend whose son is game we've
known he was gay since he was five years
old he's 17 now and all of our friends
that he's hanging out we used to say
like this kid maybe it is really it's
not a choice maybe you really are born
out here and I haven't seen this kid for
12 years to see his father and we're
talking and I'm like so how's he doing
he's like oh man it's cool he's I mean
he 17 now last time you saw him he was
five just found out he's gay and I was
like not [ __ ] you just found out like
we were having football parties in your
house and he was coming out with his
football jersey tied up in the front
that wasn't like
and nothing but I can you can't say that
you knew you have to act like you never
knew you have to hang what that was over
the top with I overcome cells like nah
not little dad the Ladykiller not little
days the vagina record for real god I
was so over the top my boy I was like
goddamn you knew this whole time he's
like I don't know what to do man and I
know you got a young son man and man to
man as dudes out here raising little
soldiers guys try to get militant up
embrace the soldiers out here in the
street if you found out your son
something big how would you make him
stop I can tell you that when I was
about 12 years old my dad caught me
smoking a cigarette and he made me smoke
20 back to back
it's not [ __ ] law seems like what
what I'm supposed to make my son change
some 20 days man you know what my son
change some 20 days I was like calm down
man I never got past the third cigarette
can you handle three rash them out don't
give them all twenty and watching my
losses
[Applause]
they're gonna find yourself coaching the
dick-sucking know something one time
stop coaching
I get asked some of the weirdest [ __ ]
about my complexion like we were down I
went down to a Charlotte and we were
performing down there and we went to
Charlotte Motor Speedway they the club
was like you guys want to go check out
the NASCAR experience it was call a 600
whatever was going on so we all went
down there checked it out but I was
ordering food in their food truck and
this dude asked me of the weirdest
clever been asked this question before
it was offensive I'm ordering my food
this dude comes up behind and he's like
a dude and I was like kind of looked
over my shoulder I'm like what's up man
it's a dude I don't want to sound
ignorant or nothing you know what that
means
I was like what's up man he's like hey
dude what are you and I was like what am
i he's like yeah I mean you know what
are you and I was like I'm a [ __ ]
carbon-based life-form i'm an oxygen
breather man well here's like enough
with a fancy word dude I was just saying
I mean you're you're kind of dark skin
but you talk regular I was incredulous I
didn't know what to say I was like well
you're white and you don't other guys
when he's like pinche to say rednecks
often do that they use foreign language
to make it appear that they're smarter
than they really are you ever watched
cops that dudes beat their wives
constantly talk to you hey I'll trade me
casa su casa
these are the foreign language hi baby
look at my new head I just bought it
well Lord be doll that's French for big
whoop rat next to me are the scariest
[ __ ] on the planet like I don't
[ __ ] the rednecks she clapping you know
what I'm talking about like people talk
about terrorists yeah Terrence was scary
but rednecks are the scariest
[ __ ] on the planet to me they
are like you've probably heard and
remember after 9/11 this one I realized
they're rednecks were the key to [ __ ]
winning wars we could take 20 rednecks
with Charlotte North Carolina and put
him in the Middle East the war would be
over gas would be 39 cents a gallon
after 9/11 everybody was upset but
rednecks were acting like planes we're
hitting trailer parks they were coming
on the news grabbed a microphone from
reporters you don't tell them my [ __ ]
backyard
you understand me use my air fins let's
pull up your tears [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
hiding up there
rednecks always repeats it twice in case
you didn't hear it the first time dude
I'm [ __ ] pissed off I'm [ __ ]
seeing red man I put the seed red they
don't wanna with me how [ __ ] wrong it
would be I'm nasty dude I'm nasty Connie
Chung was interviewing this dude he's
and snatch the mic from Connie Chung
started cussing I'm ready to go over
there and drops but the nuclear fire on
them [ __ ] over there turn that
[ __ ] to a parking lot you understand me
Connie Chung was like excuse me sir
you're on national television you can't
talk like that get the [ __ ] off me kind
of change you ain't supposed to be here
neither
right I don't know if you sleep your up
and open your eyes and I'm talking T's I
was like tisha
Vincent said some horribly
geographically wrong [ __ ] you say what
you need to do is take your Chinese ass
back to Japan with all the other
Vietnamese family Connie if something is
like what I'm not Chinese Japanese or
for you to me it's Chinese Japanese
Vietnamese chuck-e-cheese you're all to
say it's put you in different places
that's why you can't go anywhere in
Korea without seeing a [ __ ] right
next to a scary man they got that battle
cry that should have scary man we need
to utilize that battle cry over the
Middle East because they got their
battle cry over there that's to the
zong-de you go you go watch any of those
videos and then a my by loud that's some
scary [ __ ] send a poor kid from the
inner city over to the Middle East
Garcia go in that building at the end of
the block and tell me what you see aye
aye captain on my way halfway down a
name I belong
Garcia's like holy [ __ ] Sarge I can't go
in that building you hear that for a
little Lulu no nothing good ever happens
after one of those all right where's
that couch of [ __ ] from Charlotte
get your ass down there ah dude on my
way
but haulin ass down earnest fatigues
with us petits tucked into his cowboy
boots not even slowing down are you
[ __ ] me
is it funky season over here - you can
run but you can't [ __ ] you is [ __ ]
scientifically designed to scare the
[ __ ] out of anybody with any melanin in
their skin this [ __ ] fright nothing
good fouls at you it's always a [ __ ]
car in the air [ __ ] minority in the
air
[ __ ] just got real give up in a second
yeah holy [ __ ]
seriously are you serious right now
[Music]
holy [ __ ] no there's nothing about you
and the training video I did everything
I did the monkey bars I did everything
but [ __ ] you who now [ __ ] the
[ __ ] I quit what are you doing what
you look like a [ __ ] literally
and figuratively throwing in the towel
black people we invented talking ship a
rednecks perfected it you can't talk a
redneck out of a fight being a black
dude or you know somewhat black a little
bit advantages talk tough like a scare a
regular white guy got a house job family
holy similes you are rather large I
apologize I didn't see your foot oh yeah
I have a $20 bill to keep this verbal
I'm not making physical take the $20
bill I believe you people call it a dub
take the dub right now you get our way
erratic by 100 pounds he'll talk so much
[ __ ] back you're wondering why you said
anything to this crazy little
[ __ ] face it baby [ __ ] [ __ ]
now sit down oh no you can't have
regular size shoe like a human [ __ ] the
baby was that 13 [ __ ] 14 I'm a major
he was standing upright [ __ ] you
the missing link between man and ape hey
everybody in the comic let's go over to
missing link someone called Smithsonian
I want my reward
you look like number three under
evolution are you probably gotta wear
platform shoes so your knuckles don't
drag when you walk God baby I'm ball
your fists boy you ain't gonna have no
luck fighting me I'm a bad sumbitch you
ever see me fighting a bear you better
jump in and help that bear I'm nasty
I'm nasty dude you don't want with me
you're ever on the phone with God not
call you better click over and see what
the [ __ ] I want I'll fill this whole
room with the uppercut I hit you with so
many Rachel begged me for her left you
understand me we're gonna have no luck
fighting me type of luck you God you the
phone to a barrel of titties and come
I'm sucking your thumb
god damn it up bastard you'd be running
naked across a field of [ __ ] and trip
on a bit look here man
hey Oh next time you see me coming at
you you're a black dude your musical
turn it to a dance move cha cha slide
turn to the side trying to make it this
Hollywood game man trying to lose a
little bit of weight it's not going so
well this is how I knew I had to lose
some weight my son no who's now seven
when he was like two I was rocking to
sleep and I fell asleep when I woke up
he was sucking my titty
I was on the phone with the gym
immediately how much the one-year
membership something what I can't hear
you okay go ahead what my fitness goals
get my son to stop sucking my drugs
you got a bootcamp for that day handsome
there's so many facets to this Hollywood
[ __ ] man just when you think you have it
dialed in there's something else that
comes around and there's [ __ ] throws
your whole [ __ ] off it's difficult it's
long like I've been doing this [ __ ] for
26 years finally getting a shot but it's
like my wife and I were laying in bed we
were watching one of those shows like
one of those behind me music or e true
Hollywood stories we watched like four
of them back-to-back and my wife hit
pause after the fourth one she was a
holy [ __ ] I figured out the key to
success and I'm like what is it and she
was like tragedy I don't like what she
was like every one of those episodes we
just watched had has had an element of
tragedy that befell the celebrity in
question and that's where celebrity
happens you can either throw in the
towel in the face of adversity or you
can use that tragedy as fuel to propel
you to the next level and I was thinking
about holy [ __ ] you're right and she was
like you're right
and it seems like yeah and you've never
had any tragedy in your life and I
started thinking about like holy [ __ ]
you're right I haven't had any tragedy
and so I started looking around at all
the people that surround me and
wondering who I'm willing to let go of
to make this [ __ ] happen then two years
ago it happened be careful what you ask
for because it happened two years ago i
went to washington d.c to celebrate
Thanksgiving with my family weren't from
originally and it's hard for me to talk
about I know I went back there and the
night before Thanksgiving I went out
drinking with my best friends that I
grew up with and I saw my grandma's
titties that night
really guys really there's no laughs in
my face when I'm trying to open up to
you I don't know if you've ever seen
your grandma's titties but there's some
tragic [ __ ] like I'm ready to make it in
Hollywood now like I don't have ever
have you ever seen your grandma's
titties they're [ __ ] horrendous my
grandma's titties look like two-horse
knows they're all long and veiny and
once longer than the other so it looks
like a photo finish
big brown by a nose this is how it
happened old people get up early and
[ __ ] for nothing there's no reason for
old people to get up as early as they do
I'm sneaking into my grandparents house
at 2:30 in the morning
stumbling drunk I'm trying to get in the
house to as quiet as possible to evade
the text and I open the front door my
grandmother's standing there were
face-to-face scared to sit up
my grandmother's very hunched back it's
got to be hollow because it was very
deep in the residue back there my
grandma why are you out of bed at 2:30
in the morning I had no power I thought
that was the newspaper at 2:30 in the
morning that she didn't even printed yet
go back to sleep but she won't because
when you're 93 sleep is the cousin of
desert so once she's up she's up all her
friends that died died in their sleep so
she ain't Riskin is the coffee I need
just shuffle around the house mainlining
Folgers straight to the vein I I got so
much caffeine in my system I can't even
believe I can't close my eyes she's up
and all I want to do is just lay down
I'm like a four-year-old I'm just like
Oh lay down stop standing the door will
he let me past ask me a bunch of
questions who will you hang out with
tonight
who was there we're doing a lot of fine
young ladies in the house what were you
drinking tonight who was on the Wheels
of Steel you don't wait till 2:30 in the
morning when I'm shit-faced to start
trying to relate to me so I just had to
turn the tables and start asking her a
bunch of questions and make her leave me
alone grandma how did you let your back
end higher than your head
I just wanted to lay down it's just why
am i able to see her back in your
driver's license picture
what is the perpetual look like
someone's standing behind you I'm
probably the most [ __ ] up question I
asked what are we supposed to do with a
funeral when you won't lay down in the
casket I'm gonna I'll be telling the
funeral directors it we don't need the
pillowcase aving that $25 they take that
pillow as long as she hasn't touched a
pillow in 17 years
we're gonna have to call her wake of the
back and put her arm up on the side we
can't close the casket right now make it
look like she's our convertible she's
the tub
all I want to do is just lay down I want
I'm like that I'm the type of drunk that
I just want to kick my shoes off and
fall face-first of the pillow and just
knock out and that's where I am I kick
my shoes off I fall into the pillow and
I'm about to pass out and everybody's
been there where you've been hearing
that a little ethereal state of being
half awake and half asleep and you hear
something that startles you awake but
you can't tell if you really heard it or
dreamt that you heard it isn't that the
scariest hit in the world especially
when you're home alone on the house
locked up tight you're passing out
almost asleep and then you hear
something now if you're in your living
room and you fall asleep on the couch
and you hear a noise in the living room
it wakes you up and you might go what
the [ __ ] was that you might like sneak
into the other room and grab a baseball
bat or a knife or something to be like
what the [ __ ] someone in my house but
something about being asleep in bed
makes you lazy as [ __ ] for you this is
for your own safety you don't even get
out of bed you just start greeting the
potential murderer you hear a noise like
Hello
does that ever stop it murder from
happening like the murderer is coming to
the house of the knife and here's a
little hello
yeah
I wasn't established [ __ ] out here but
I'm a sucker for a warm salutation that
greeting was warm as hell I was so
anyway that's where I am I'm passing out
I hear this [ __ ] I've never heard before
you can forever spent the night with old
people you know they got to get rid of
this phlegm they got a hack up these
chest clams for the first time doing
this I'm all the way awake now I'm under
the covers like a bee out
after like four or five minutes of
nothing happening my fear started
turning an anger and I'm getting mad who
the [ __ ] is watching Jurassic Park 247
in the morning I keep the copper soft
stumble out into the living room to turn
the TV down if not off and when I get
out to the living room the TV's already
off that's scared the [ __ ] out of me
that told me whatever is making those
noises in the [ __ ] house and like I
said I'm half-black and half-white at
that point my two halves completely
separated the black half of me wanted to
get the [ __ ] out of the house
immediately
the white half had the insatiable urge
to investigate and the white half one
I'm inching my way down the hallway
towards the only light on in the house
that's coming out of the bathroom
whatever it is is in that [ __ ]
bathroom I don't even know the prayer
I'm just making up [ __ ]
i peek around and the bathroom i see the
most horrifying gruesome McCobb [ __ ]
I've ever seen in my life I see my
grandmother standing in front of the
sink wearing those horrible orthopedic
support compression stockings from the
hospital she's wearing those and that's
it
choking up longer titties banging it the
worst part is I've seen this happen from
the back the longest gnarliest titties
banging off the saddest ass cheeks I've
ever seen in my life every time I'm
swinging back around the front they're
grazing the sink it sounds like a full
court basketball guess I scared her
startled her she did a 180 and almost
took me out with her I was drunk when I
moved quick like I said what titties is
lower than the other one so I had to
matrix the first
I have enough time to get my timing down
to double ducks the second one dragging
across was Tyler now she's just standing
there looking at my grandma close the
door I'm sorry baby is the light
bothering you Micheline oh now that I'm
looking at those illuminated funbags
yeah kill the lights
they're awful like grapefruits and tube
socks you look like a pro hacky sack
player every time you go up the steps
I did those jokes on TV don't clap but
I'm gonna get his level
I already got in trouble for doing those
on television one time she saw me do
those jokes she cut and I knew I told
her to watch it was a huge mistake she
called me the next day and I just sent
it to voicemail because I knew it was it
about I didn't want to hear it I was in
a good mood from the show I was like I'm
not listen to this [ __ ] send it to
voicemail and then later on that night I
listened to the voicemail it was
enraging it was like a minute of her
yelling at me and the worst part about
her yelling at me about doing the jokes
about her titties was that she leaves
her name at the end of the voicemail
like I have no idea who the [ __ ] it is I
guess the big reveal I don't you talk
about my tenants for 20 goddamn minutes
on national television
what the hell is wrong with you I know
you think everything is a joke but this
ain't no joke is about real titties in
my real life I told all my girls from
church my church my Bible study class to
watch my grandson on TV now my kids go
back to my Bible study classes all my
girlfriends every time I hear a big long
tinny Margaret coming you talk about my
teacher 20 goddamn it is on desert Elvis
you need to knock that off leave my
titties in my blouse and not on your
routine and you better call me back and
let me know you got this message this is
grandma by the way
followed by her signature hang-up which
is another minute to have her trying to
hang up the fantastic thank you so much
mom guys job they'll talk about font is
all tibidabo I'm talking to you I used
to be able to do the helicopter little
if they little see longer that down to
page of this baby
[Music]
you know you live with you feed me no
one can resist the 46 long paisa shake
my opinions at the long titty Club of
Chicago they look like fools the George
Washington Carver slathered a little
peanut butter he chances like a year
looks like a tree ring this is my ramp
come here
yeah baby come here give your grandma
kids come here baby dig deep in their
pockets
what's the bids got to do to make it
right up in here sit at the back of the
bus
[Music]
you